what have you learned about human beings
human nature and the human mind from
those who suffer from psychiatric
maladies
for those for whom this fabric is warped
and one thing we learn as biologists is
that when something breaks
you see
what the original
unbroken
part was for and we see this in genetics
we see this in biochemistry
it's known that when you have a mutated
gene
sometimes the gene is turned up in
strength they're turned down in strength
and that lets you see what it was
originally for you can infer
true function from dysfunction
and this is a theme that i thought
needed to be shared
and needed to be made communicable to
the to the way public to everybody
people who
which is i think uh almost all of us who
think and care about the inner workings
of our minds but who also
care for those who have been suffering
who have
mental health disorders who face
challenges
but then more broadly
it's a very much larger story than the
present there's a
story to be told where the protagonist
really is the human mind and that was
one thing i wanted to share as well in
projections is that broader story but
still anchored in the moment of
patience of people of
experiences of the moment
is there a clear line between
dysfunction and function disorder and
order
this is always debated in psychiatry
probably more so than any other you know
medical specialty
i'm a psychiatrist i'm i treat patients
still uh i see
acutely ill
people who come to the emergency room
where there's no doubt that this is not
something that's working well where the
manifestation of disease is so powerful
where the person is suffering so greatly
where they cannot
continue as they are
but of course it's a spectrum and there
are people who are closer to the to the
realm of being able to work okay in
their jobs but suffer from some small
dysfunction and everywhere in between
in psychiatry we're careful to say we
don't call it a disease or disorder
unless
there's a disruption in social or
occupational functioning
but of course psychiatry has a long way
to go in terms of developing
quantitative tests we don't have
blood draws we don't have imaging
studies that we can use to diagnose
and so that line ultimately
that you're asking about between order
and disorder function and dysfunction
it's operational of the moment how are
things working
can we just like linger on the terms for
a second so this uh disease
uh dysfunction
how careful should we be using those
words can we just even in this
conversation
um from a
sort of technical perspective but also a
human perspective
how
quick
should we be
in saying that schizophrenia
uh depression
autism
as we kind of go down this uh the across
the spectrum of different
maladies like
just to use the word dysfunction and
disease
i would say to give ourselves license to
capture the whole spectrum let's say
disorder because that that captures
truly i think the essence of it which is
we need to talk about it when it's not
working when there's disorder and that
that's the fairest and and uh
you know most uh inclusive term to use
so is it fair to assume that basically
every
member of the human species suffers from
a large number of disorders then
well and we just have to pick which ones
are are debilitating and for each person
you know if you if you look at the
numbers
there are
uh
you know if you look at how our
mental health disorders are currently
defined you can uh look at population
prevalence
values for all these disorders and you
can
come up with estimates that
somebody
will have a lifetime prevalence of
having a psychiatric disorder that
approaches 25 or so and so that's
and in some studies it could be more
some studies it could be less now what
do we do with that number what does that
mean and in some ways that's the essence
of what i was hoping to approach with
the book is to reflect on this spectrum
that exists for all the disorders there
is
taking nothing away from the severity
and the suffering that comes at the
extreme end of these illnesses but
nearly every one of them exists on a
spectrum of severity from
nearly functional to completely
dysfunctional life-threatening and and
even fatal
and so that that that number 25 more or
less it doesn't capture uh that that
spectrum of
of uh severity to lingard that number
where do those numbers come from is it
self-report is it people who
show up and say i need help
is it somebody else that points out that
person needs help
or is it like estimates that even go
beyond that for people who don't ask for
help or suffering quietly
alone when you look at self-report
numbers that then those numbers get even
higher beyond 25 percent or more
those the most rigorous studies are
done with structured psychiatric
interviews where people
who are trained in eliciting symptoms
carefully do complete psychiatric
inventories of individuals and these are
time-consuming laborious studies that
not often repeated when they're done
they're they're done well
but
very often you'll see a report or
something in the news of a very high
number
for some disorder or or symptom and very
often
if it's shockingly high that's coming
from a self-report of a person
and so that's another another issue that
we have again take nothing away from the
severity in reality and
biological nature of these disorders
which are very genetic very you know we
we understand that these are very
biological
and yet
we lack right now the lab tests and the
blood draws to make the diagnoses we'll
talk about it just how biological they
are because it's a that too is a mystery
i mean
you know in terms of from a perspective
of how to probe into the disease how to
understand it and how to help it
so some of it could be neurobiological
some of it could be uh just the the
dance of human emotion and interaction
and the
it's like uh
it will it is love when it works and is
love when it breaks down uh biological
or is it something else
you